at the core of your belief system is
something you call the a prime number
maze I'm curious I'm curious we gotta
start there sure if we can start
anywhere with mathematics let's go all
right great a rat can be trained to turn
at every even number or every third
number in a maze to to get some cheese
but evidently it can't be trained to
turn at prime numbers
two three five seven and then 11 and so
on and so forth that's just too abstract
and frankly if most humans were dropped
into a prime number maze
they probably wouldn't be able to figure
it out either you know they'd have to
start counting and so and actually
pretty difficult to figure out what the
Turning you know rule was
yet the rule is actually very simple
and so the thing I think about a lot is
just how many patterns in life are we
just like these rats and we're trapped
in a prime number Maze and if we had
just a little bit more you know
cogitation if we had you know a little
bit more cognitive ability a little bit
more whether it's uh you know brain
machine at your face or just better
physics we could just figure out the
next step in that prime numbers we could
just see it we could see the grid right
and that's what I think about like that
that's a big thing that drives me
is figuring out how we can actually
conceive understand that prime number
maze that we're living in so understand
which patterns are just complex enough
that they are beyond the limit of human
cognition yes and uh what do you make
that are the limits the human cognition
a feature or a bug
I think mostly a bug I admire vermonagen
I admire uh you know Feynman I admired
these great mathematicians and
physicists who were just able to
see things that others couldn't
and just by writing it down you know
that's that's a Leap Forward you know
people talk about it's not the idea it's
execution but that's for trivial ideas
for great ideas for Maxwell's equations
or Newton's laws or you know Quantum
electrodynamics or some of ramonigen's
identities that really does bring us
forward especially when you can check
them you don't know how they work right
you have the phenomenological if you
don't have the theory underneath it and
then that stimulates the advancement of
theory to figure out why is this thing
actually working that's actually you
know statmac you know arose in part from
the kind of phenomenological studies
that were basically being done where
people are just getting steam engines
and so on to work and then they kind of
abstracted out thermodynamics and so on
from that right so the the practice led
the theory rather than vice versa to
some extent that's happening neural
networks now as you're aware right and I
think that's
um so just something that's true and
that works you know if we don't know yet
that's amazing and it pulls us forward
so I I do think that the limits are are
more of a bug than a feature is there
something that humans will never be able
to figure out about our universe about
the theory about the practice of our
universe yeah people will typically
quote cordell's in completeness with for
such a question and uh yeah there are
things that are probably unknowable or
provably unprovable
um but I think you can often get an
approximate solution you know the the
Hilbert you know you know Hilbert's
problems like we will know we must know
uh at least we should know that we can
know push to get at least an approximate
solution push to know that we can't no
at least we push back that Darkness
enough so that we have lit up that
corner of the intellectual Universe okay
let's actually take a bit of a tangent
and explore a bit in a way that I did
not expect we would but let's talk about
the nature of reality briefly I don't
know if you're familiar with the work of
Don Hoffman no I don't I know Roger
Penrose has like his Road to Reality
series for like basic physics going up
to everything we know but go ahead tell
me it's even Wilder yeah in modern
physics we start the question of what is
fundamental and what is emergent in this
beautiful Universe of ours and there's a
bunch of folks who think that space-time
as we know it the four-dimensional space
is emergent it's not fundamental to the
physics of the universe and the same may
you argue I think Sean Carroll is one of
them is that time itself the way we
experience it is also emergent it's not
fundamental to the way our universe
works anyway those are uh the technical
term I apologize for swearing those are
the Mind [ __ ] of modern physics but if
we
stroll along that road further we get
somebody like Donald Hoffman who makes
the evolutionary case that the reality
we perceive with our eyes is not only an
abstraction of objective reality but
it's actually completely detached like
we're in a video game essentially that's
consistent between each consistent for
All Humans but it doesn't it's not at
all connected to physical reality
because it's an illustration version of
the simulation hypothesis is that his in
a very distant way but
as the simulation says that there's a
sort of computational nature to reality
and then there's a kind of a programmer
that creates this reality and so on no
he's he says that we humans have a brain
that is able to perceive the environment
and uh evolution is produced from
primitive life to complex life on Earth
produce the kind of brain that doesn't
at all need to sense the reality uh
directly so like this table
according to Donald Hoffman is not there
well so like not not just as an
abstraction like we don't sense the
molecules that make up the table but all
of this is fake interesting so you know
I I tend to be more of a hard science
person right and so
um you know so just on that people talk
about qualia you know like
is your perception of green the
different different from my perception
of green and you know my counter
argument on that is well we know
something about you know spectrum of
light and we can build artificial eyes
and if we can build artificial eyes
which we can you know they're like
they're not amazing but you can actually
you can do that you can build artificial
ears and so on obviously we can build
recording devices and you know for
cameras and things like that well
operationally the whole concept of your
perception of green you see green is
purple icy green is green or what I call
Green it doesn't seem to add up because
it does seem like we can do engineering
around it right so the Hoffman thing I
get why people more broadly will talk
about a simulation is because you know
it's like fine and many others have
talked about how uh math is surprisingly
useful to describe the world you know
like very simple equations give rise
these complex phenomenal Wolfram is also
on this
um from it from different angle with a
cellular automata stuff but um so
suspicious how well it works yeah but on
their hand it's like uh you know
it is
yet we're still also in a prime number
maze you know there's things we just
don't understand and um you know so also
the within the constraints of the
non-prime numbers
we find math to be extremely effective
surprisingly effective yeah exactly so
maybe maybe the math we have gets us
through the equivalent of the even turns
and the odd turns but there's math we
don't yet have that is more complex or
more complex rules for other parts this
is probably all our age and all just
threats in a cage I know it gets like
very abstract but you know there are
unsolved problems in in physics you know
like the condensed matter space there's
a lot of interesting stuff happening my
recollection I may be you know out of
date on this like things like Sony
luminescence we don't know exactly how
they work and sometimes those things
that are like at the edges of physics
you know in the late 1800s I think
Rutherford somebody I think as
Rutherford said you know basically all
physics is being discovered Etc and that
was obviously before quantum mechanics
you know that that sort of educates
people are looking at the bomber and the
passion series and seeing you know this
weird thing you know with the hydrogen
Spectrum it was quantized and you know
that led to uh like the sort of
phenomenological set of observations
that led to quantum mechanics and and
everything and you know sometimes I
think the UAP stuff might be like that
right people immediately go to aliens
for UAP like the unidentified aerial
phenomena right and people have been uh
there's surprising amount of stuff out
there on this the UK is Declassified a
bunch of material you know Harry Reid
was the sender has talked about this
it's not obviously it's not obviously
political thing it which is good it's
something that
is is there something happening there
right and people that thought for a long
time that the UAP thing was a like
American
um kind of counter propaganda to cover
up their new spy planes that were spying
over the Soviet Union to make anybody
who talked about them seem
you know crazy and and hysterical or
whatever but
if the UAP thing is real
it could be atmospheric phenomena like
you know like the Aurora Borealis or the
northern lights but some things we don't
understand it could be something like
the uh the bomber and passion series uh
you know which were the observations of
like emission Spectra before quantum
mechanics so that's like another option
as opposed to doesn't exist or Little
Green Men it could be physics we don't
understand yet